apple is finally fixing the ipad pro and
making it pro again yes we just got the
most solid confirmation that apple is
completely revamping ipad os 16 at wwdc
in just a couple of days and the best
part of all is that we actually have
leaks and patents to back it up but
before i get into mark german's new
bombshell leak report on ipad os 16 i
want to go through the story of how
apple ruined the launch of the m1 ipad
pro when apple revealed the current ipad
pro back in april of last year we were
totally blown away because apple decided
to give it the same exact m1 chip from
the new apple silicon mac lineup and not
only that but we were shocked when we
saw that the performance wasn't even
getting throttled compared to the m1 max
despite being impossibly thin so because
the performance of the m1 ship was so
overkill for an ipad and it literally
still is today many people including
myself expected apple's ipad os 15
update at last year's wwdc
to completely change the way the ipad
works finally making it pro again and
there were literally people buying the
m1 ipad pro in anticipation of an
awesome ipad os 15 update because that's
the only way anyone could make sense of
the m1 chip making its way to the ipad
pro which was already a bit overkill
with the previous a12z chip and the fact
that apple gave the ipad pro a full-on
thunderbolt port gave people a lot of
hope because apple's file system was
pretty bad in terms of actually being
able to utilize that thunderbolt port
properly but by far the biggest hint was
that the m1 ipad pro was able to be
configured with up to 16 gigabytes of
ram if you bought a one terabyte model
and this was a big deal because we all
found out in may that ipad os 14 limited
apps to only up to 5 gigabytes of ram
each way less than the 16 gig ram ipad
pro so that was basically nail in the
coffin proof that apple just had to give
us a crazy good pro focused ipad os 15
update and then
wwdc finally came along and apple
completely disappointed everyone in
basically every way possible there was
no ipad os multitasking overhaul like
everyone expected external display
support was still terrible with black
bars on the sides since the aspect ratio
doesn't match up there were no new pro
apps to take advantage of the m1 chip's
overkill performance and even with ipad
os 15 the 5 gigabyte ram limit remained
until months later they did however show
off the new universal control feature
which allows you to use one mouse and
keyboard to control both your ipad and
your mac but that's basically a slap in
the face because it requires a mac
instead of just making the ipad more pro
and it didn't even come out until
earlier this year and making things even
worse when we actually downloaded ipad
os 15 beta we had various issues like
thunderbolt performance being very slow
compared to thunderbolt on the mac and
other issues like ssds getting corrupted
because there still isn't an eject
button and that's when we started seeing
more and more posts and comments by
people who were returning their m1 ipad
pros because of how disappointed they
were with ipad os 15. but now it looks
like we finally have some confirmation
for mark german that we are in fact
getting some major multitasking updates
with ipad west 16 so let's jump right in
now jumping right in as you can see i
have mark german's twitter open right
here he actually works for bloomberg
business and he's actually one of the
most reliable apple leakers and analysts
out there right now because his accuracy
rating is very high despite having a
massive amount of different leaks that
he has shared over the past years now he
just posted a new tweet this morning
sharing his new bloomberg story saying
that apple plans to make the ipad more
like a laptop and less like a phone he's
saying that wwdc is going to be pretty
jam packed expecting a lot of different
upgrades with ipad os 16 watch os 9 and
other upgrades in terms of software and
some hardware as well which we just
talked about in our wwdc video that we
posted the other day now let's jump in
to the ipad os 16 updates because i
believe that is what everybody is going
to be talking about i mean this is going
to be a huge change now jumping into his
bloomberg article he's saying that apple
will announce significant changes to the
ipad software next week part of a push
to make the device more like a laptop
and less like a phone now he's saying
that this is going to be a major
software update and it's going to have a
redesigned multitasking interface that
makes it easier to see what apps are
open and switch between tasks said the
people or his sources who asked not to
be identified just yet and on top of
that he's saying that it will also let
users resize app windows and offer new
ways for users to handle multiple apps
at once now that
is exactly what everybody has been
asking for for years and i remember a
few years ago when apple made their
advertisement which basically said
what's a computer implying that the ipad
is now a computer i made a review video
and i said the one thing i want the ipad
pro to do is let me resize different app
windows and have them on the screen at
the same time i said we need that in
order for the ipad pro to actually
become a laptop replacement and it looks
like that is exactly what apple is going
to be doing with ipad os 16. now moving
on he's saying that the new ipad
interface will be one of the biggest
upgrades announced at the conference
which i fully believe because right now
ipad users can either run apps in a full
screen view like on an iphone or run two
apps side by side and the company also
lets users add a scaled down version of
a third app by sliding it over from the
side but personally i think that sucks i
never really use it it's not that great
but thankfully the changes will expand
upon that interface so they're finally
gonna make it work a lot better and the
awesome thing about mark german's
confirmation is that it basically
confirms some apple patents which were
filed which a lot of people didn't
believe but now he's confirmed it saying
that we are getting all of those changes
so check out these patents from apple as
you can see
this shows an ipad interface with an
apple pencil
but you have a mac os like user
experience including you have the finder
different menu bars right here and two
different windows one stacked onto the
other with some icons almost like a
desktop interface
which reminds me of samsung dex for
their tablets which works absolutely
amazingly it's just awesome dex is
amazing not only that but they showed
off some different new keyboard cases
that attach in different ways so maybe
we might see a new keyboard case coming
with a new ipad pro later this year but
jumping back to this mac os like
interface the thing that blows my mind
is that we actually got a leak from
majin buu on twitter saying that apple
is developing a smart system for ipad os
apps will continue to open full screen
but automatically shrink when connected
to a keyboard and a trackpad which is
basically the magic keyboard case which
is absolutely amazing he's saying that
internally it's called apple mixer we
don't know if it'll be included in ipad
os 16 or not which now i think we are
because mark german just confirmed it
and the craziest thing of all he says it
should be m1 ipad exclusive now this is
totally genius by apple because both the
ipad pro and the ipad air now have the
m1 chip and i believe they'll continue
to get m series chips moving forward
into the future so whether you have an
ipad air or an ipad pro you'll be able
to use this new mac os like interface
this new pro mode with multiple windows
and better multitasking which means you
gotta pay more for those ipads which is
great for apple and not only that it
requires a magic keyboard case or a case
with a keyboard and trackpad which is
really good because both the ipad air
and the ipad pro support the magic
keyboard case so basically apple is
going to be making a ton of money now
not only that but
buu also said that apple is working on a
version of final cut for the ipad now
it's not going to be on par with the
actual final cut pro that we have on the
mac but it is going to be final cut
coming to the ipad which was leaked in
previous leaks from john prosser and it
looks like we're finally getting it and
this is a really big deal because we
know that we have an overkill amount of
performance with the m1 ship but nowhere
to spend that extra power well here you
go we have pro apps like final cut
hopefully logic and xcode as well coming
with ipad os 16 and having this new
multitasking mode that's kind of like
mac os is going to be an absolutely huge
deal and i think apple is going to sell
a ton of ipad airs and ipad pros now if
you have a hard time imagining what it's
going to look like we actually made a
video a month ago talking about this
whole ipad os 16 and how apple's going
gonna fix the ipad pro but within that
video we actually showed off some
concepts from parker ordolani and i have
them right over here so as you can see
multitasking in his imagination shows
off the different apps in a much better
view because you have the small apps
separated from the social apps
potentially like podcasts and your web
pages and larger apps so that's pretty
nice right there you also have popover
apps which i think is awesome because it
looks like it's resizable and you can
move it around like for the apple music
app and also being able to pair
different apps together side by side up
to three or four so i like his
imagination even better i like that you
can have this dock where you can hover
over an app and have different tabs and
pages shown where you can actually close
them down and this right here is what i
really want having stacks built into the
dock so you can open up your files and
have access to them more easily another
cool thing is a redesigned apple pencil
menu that's kind of like this wheel that
he showed off which i think would be
great for artists and they would
definitely appreciate that but the one
thing that i really really want is a new
display studio mode like parker showed
off right here actually having automatic
aspect ratio resizing when you hook up
to an external display from your ipad
and having this new interface that would
be amazing but with all that said i
honestly think that ipad os 16 is gonna
be the best ipad software update ever
and i honestly think that it's going to
fix the m1 ipad pro alongside the new m2
ipad pro that's going to be coming this
year and i think a lot of people are
going to be buying them so if you
completely disagree with my thoughts
then comment them down below but if you
enjoyed the video click the circle above
to subscribe definitely check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]